[Music]
it was the perfect day to be
in the kitchen when we met chef keith
[ __ ] outside a typical toronto gray
winter overcast dominated the skies
so read into this what you will but the
sun's rays found a way through
and let's be honest we could all use a
little sunlight in these trying times
or in the case of this story a little
more food on our plates
even today the headlines from a year ago
are still hard to bear
the coronavirus are spreading at an
alarming rate and as everything began to
shut down
keith got on the phone with long time
friend and fellow chef john placo
planting the seed for what would become
the busiest professional year of their
lives
and it's not like they weren't busy
before
chef john is the mad scientist of the
two an expert in molecular gastronomy
the chemistry of cuisine
he was set to launch a chocolate
business in 2020 to complement his
catering business
where he makes unique desserts like
edible helium balloons
i was invited to russia to the world
chef's organization to to present there
so it was looking like it's going to be
like one of the best years
and all of a sudden it just came to a
screeching halt
every part of my business the consulting
the airport restaurant
the sales of ingredients for molecular
cuisine
and the events like everything just
completely stopped
well it's cooled down a little bit just
pull that skin right off
nice chicken chef keith rolls in
different circles he's the beloved
teacher of the two
always thinking of new ways to challenge
his students at thistletown collegiate
a school in rexdale one of toronto's
most diverse yet
economically challenged neighborhoods if
the main course he teaches is the
culinary arts
dessert is a heavy dose of empathy
and he leads by example when he noticed
some of his students weren't eating
properly at home
he started up a food bank inside the
school
and every month at least pre-pandemic
his class would prepare a meal for a
youth or women's shelter
but they never know what food will be
donated so they're forced to improvise
with some cinnamon where would i be
oh i got it right you got cinnamon sir
yeah just as chef keith did when he won
an episode of chop canada
so that means you chef keith [ __ ] are
our chopped canada champion and you're
gonna make a lot of kids happy because
you just won ten thousand dollars
congratulations
fantastic thank you very much in true to
form he gave his students
extra motivation to cheer him on they
did because
uh i i said when i went on the show that
i would uh
use if i won that i would use the money
to uh
help fund a trip to europe and so uh
that's what i did i took the ten
thousand dollar prize and
we went to spain and france with the
students with the students
yeah so
these are our chefs and this was their
challenge
it all started with keith giving me a
call and saying can you come out
to humber college they've got a lot of
food there classes have stopped
they want to donate it as one of the
larger colleges in the gta
humber buys a lot of food for its
culinary program and cafeterias
but with everything shut down in march
2020 it had
fifty thousand dollars worth of fresh
food and no one to eat it
until the two chefs contacted food banks
in mississauga
which were experiencing a spike in users
we saw
a a pretty quick stiff increase of
17 to 24 percent and then year to date
we're seeing at times we see up to 30
percent
numbers like that are hard for any food
bank to swallow but the heartburn really
begins when you consider they rely
almost exclusively
on community donations and that was
about to dry up for peter costello
of mississauga's eden food for change
because his two
biggest suppliers schools and churches
were shut down
churches and and faith groups are are
suffering
as well and so where they traditionally
were good supporters of us
they tried to but they could they
couldn't they couldn't do it and that
no longer with the schools operating uh
could we
get with get support from say a toonie
tuesday kind of
event and things like that so the two
chefs had pretty good timing
but there was a problem all that food
from humber as well as more donated by
hotels and industry suppliers
was originally intended to be used in
weddings and large events
all of it fresh and perishable the clock
was ticking
and being the chef that they are wasting
food of that quality and in that
quantity
was never going to happen
to me it's almost criminal to be
throwing away good food when people are
they've lost their jobs they're
struggling money-wise and and
to find food for their families it
should not be going to landfill
and this is where it gets a little crazy
because they had inadvertently found an
overlooked element of food insecurity
shelters and food banks were still
offering baskets filled with
non-perishables
but with their kitchens closed they
could no longer offer prepared meals for
seniors and people with disabilities
who can't cook on their own
so chefs john and keith along with their
wives turned on their stoves
rolled up their sleeves and went to work
preparing full meals and desserts
from their home kitchens how many hours
a day were you in the kitchen
cooking oh probably probably
10 or 12 hours a day it was non-stop it
was from morning till night
six seven days a week yeah it was
non-stop so we're probably up at about
40 to 50
000 you know meals that we've sent out
to
shelters and food banks between four
people between four people
that doesn't seem remarkable at all
words spread about what they were doing
and soon a few carloads of food
would become truckloads chef's warehouse
along with other suppliers that sell
food in bulk to restaurants
had skids of product it could either
give away
or throw out sales manager lee bagley
says
there was almost too much i was uh
i guess optimistic that they could be
put to use but i realistically
knowing that he was going to be doing
them out of his home kitchen it was
seen to be a a big dream that they could
uh use them all three times a week i
fill up the truck and there's
there's got to be 500 to 1000 worth of
food in that truck ever
three times a week it's definitely
helped me
sleep better at night knowing that it's
uh it's been
gone to a great cause
[Music]
try and repeat the garnish with the
flavor
it's safe to say their passion for
feeding people evolved into a mission
which they estimate has saved upwards of
a million dollars worth of food
they gave their time and energy and with
only a handful of monetary donations
they shouldered almost all of the extra
costs themselves
from an outside perspective you could
say they gave
more than they received you couldn't be
more wrong
you've changed yeah i've changed i've
changed
in a good way yeah in a good way yeah
i haven't focused on all the stuff that
i can't do because of the pandemic
i focused on what i can do
because of the pandemic and what i can
do is do what i love to do
cook and share my food with people